now I want to get to since we're talking
about horror movies and I have to be
honest with you my friend
I regret watching the movie directed get
out okay because my thought of you and
my perception of you changed okay before
like when you're doing key and Peele
right now you go yeah I know it's great
but I've seen it mm-hmm I know that he
can do that
you know I witnessed it live for years I
know your talent level right and I know
that you're as extremely creative dude
and you have a good work ethic but when
I saw get out I was going [ __ ] this is
next-level [ __ ]
and I regret watching it because then
now how do i how much and now it's fine
when I saw you it's fine because you
look you you you we lock eyes we're
we're in we'll figure it out but there
is a moment where you go wow he's Scott
he's that's the next level he's out of
this world he's beyond he's beyond the
comedy he's beyond it's a different
category now and then when you see the
dude it's like like it's almost as if
you turned into JJ Abrams and a little
weird away that's no because it's I'll
tell you why it's not because you
directed a [ __ ] movie because I have
friends then all directed a [ __ ] movie
when you you know you've been doing your
friends movies and you watch it you go
that's the worst piece of [ __ ] ever / -
yes yeah and then when they go what
would you say it's great I'm so into
this talk right now cuz I want to kill
ya give you some good but when you watch
get out you're going number one I've
never seen this before ever this type of
movie it's so relevant it's very social
in many ways but it's also weird it's
got sort of like a Jacob's Ladder kind
of vibe to it where it's like it's in
it's just got a weird vibe in itself the
energy of the movie right and it is it
does he wins at the end which is great
but my only problem
that I guess is why the [ __ ] is there an
old Japanese dude with the white people
well all right this is and this is like
I seem to be like a talking point what
people are writing essays about I'll
tell you I'll tell you in a second but I
I do want to say since the beginning of
my career in Hollywood you are been one
of the people who has always believed in
me maybe to some maybe some of it was
like you just being like oh no so yeah I
mean I have to say this is one of the
thing I was and I was like testing have
you seen it have you seen it cuz you've
always you know back in the day we go
around it's like you know you you know
you're the [ __ ] face of MADtv and
people recognizing you and people know
you from your stand-up and everything
and you'd always be like wait wait buddy
wait it's gonna be you know you're gonna
be huge you're gonna be huge yeah you
talk to me like Robert Evans I believe
that and you believe that and that means
a great deal to me and so thank you but
I feel like you are some in a Hollywood
of filled with people who have you know
[ __ ] slam doors and my face and all
of our faces it just keeps happening
you're one of the people that I feel
like I've taken great Drive from an
inspiration and because we live in a
world of bewilderment mm-hmm we do there
is something about I'm not saying that
in a but there's something about because
I don't know what his marijuana usage is
now it's it's rock bottom none
it's let's just say it's rock I'm not
I'm not saying I'm not saying I don't
smoke weed you know I I'm not gonna put
that on it cuz then it's gonna be a few
yeah it'll feel weird yeah but the thing
is after years of smoking weed and being
creative the way I completed this script
was by not smoking weed yeah it's like
the inspiration part weed helped yeah
the execution part the final and the
productivity that needs to for the
finish because when I heard sunken place
in the movie right yeah it is something
that he would
say yeah or we would say you like we be
in an apartment right you're mean and
we're really in the sunken place yeah
right it's a cat this is we're very
Bobby yeah yeah yeah and when he heard
that in the movie I got that oh my gosh
my god and he would get what happens
ever seen anyway at the time yeah now is
your now oh babe leave in one I'm not
not a not oh not a weed guy now yeah not
a weed guy right bye everyone
dip your toes in hey you know I'm right
there if I need it right I might need it
first a little inspiration
exactly dude that's what upset and you
know what dude I was sober all that time
I met you do yeah I never sweated you
about a dog no no yeah see him walking
down Highland first of all he just got a
car oh wow yeah I got a car I so we hit
a hundred million yeah car with a bow
it's taken public transportation no I
was it was I that would be pathetic no
nothing no my wife drove me everywhere
poor Chelsea yeah I mean yeah I mean
Syria DJ yeah talk about doing a service
right but we would literally watch him
walk down the street and we would just
pull over and pick him up
yeah it was great yeah you know good
friends and people would always be like
what you [ __ ] I mean you this frustrated
you all my great news like [ __ ] just
get a car [ __ ] Drive my my own thing
was like why would I get a car and what
the yeah and I was like the day you
stopped coming to pick me up I'm gonna
have to get a car yeah oh you should've
seen the way Park by the way but would
mom be him was destroyed the car it was
not the best part yeah yeah it's not my
best work but I was you were
looking at me it was like first time
you'd see me drive it was a lot of
pressure yeah God but watching him pull
up in that how old are you when you got
your license 36 amazing I thought I was
old and I got my license at 24 yeah yeah
no I like a year year and a half did
Chelsea make you they shouldn't make me
but she asked me to yeah for a while and
and you know she asked me in the
beginning I was like yeah do it and of
course like two years went by I didn't
do it and then eventually I did it I
sacked up it part of it was not smoking
weed anymore Wow Wow yeah yeah well you
know what do whatever you choose to do
that's you you're a mean mm-hmm I don't
give a [ __ ] let me say this so I
remember those times in your apartment
and stuff sitting there yeah right and
you pitching me ideas and talking about
things you know I mean did we ever talk
about get out we never really did I
really yeah maybe a little bit maybe
it's MADtv both of you guys has sunken
places yeah yeah yeah marginalized you
know you know it did two things for me I
don't know if I would have gotten a job
after that if I didn't get that right so
I think that I cuz I remember not having
an agent and then getting it at least I
got an agent and it put me on the map in
terms of that so I can't you would I
mean you're you're so much better than I
show you of course you would have gotten
well I I know but that's just
assumptions right that's no that's
that's the sunken place to talk thing
yeah the sunken please cut me there I
had a I had a life crisis after I
watched a movie because I had to think
about the sunken place and I had these
reoccurring dreams and I had to write it
on a journal and get it out of me
because I I totally know what a sunken
places and I'm like that's what I've
been dreaming of my whole life and it
takes me back to a place where I feel
desperate and scared right I you know I
get this a lot of people with
xiety attacks or depression or something
you know I've gotten a lot of people
reaching out in pain like this is what
it feels like man how did you know and
it was one of these things we're writing
in I mean you can just imagine like
writing it that that moment you sort of
figure out the sunken place and you like
these [ __ ] are gonna lose their
minds seriously you know you know
something universe I always thought of
it like I always had this thought of you
know when you're about to when you're
when you're about you're about to go to
sleep and you feel yourself falling but
then you wake yourself up yeah so I
always thought what if you didn't wake
up where would you fall to and so that
was the first nugget of that thing and
it could be even be on par with like
sleep paralysis you know where the
monsters come and you can't you see the
man with a hat and all of those there's
there's something about about dreams
that yeah your your brain is
interpreting why your neural czar shut
down and why you're not yeah move so
your brains putting together this
mythology and the dreams it's like it's
also it's like Nightmare on Elm Street
you know she's like walking up the
stairs and marshmallow and she can't get
up the stairs I feel like I can't get
away from this yeah that's always hate
having dreams of fighting people because
I can never swing right never lands
right I'm always missing yeah yeah do
you dream was bored remember his dreams
at all I barely do either that's
actually I know I dream I forget about
it that was a sign of depression for
some people is the lack of dreams forget
about me just forget about it the moment
you wake up and have a thought outside
of sleeping is the moment you forget
about your dreams lipton why why
sometimes especially back in the day I
would dream and it would just be vivid
and I would wake up and I would know and
I'm like what and I loved these dreams
mean those are inspiring yeah do you
think it has something to do with though
that you live like I live
how do I say this in an excitable world
right I perform live you know me we do
things you don't mean that it's very
exciting so like when I was had no job
and I was in my early 20s I had no
future
I was vividly remembering my dreams
because maybe that's what I clung on to
but because of my I don't know that my
lifestyle do you think that that has
something to do what they don't know I
mean you stop dreaming because all your
dream dream but I like I just don't
remember or they're not as impactful or
maybe you're getting older cuz the
quality of your sleep as you get older
is deteriorating yeah maybe it's here
you're doing so much expression and like
you know isn't like dreams kind of like
bottled up things supposed to resolve
it's like your sub-conscience and a mix
of other things but it's supposed to be
sleep is suppose to be restorative and
you're supposed to resolve conflicts in
the back of your mind the only dreams I
do remember our relapse dreams oh gosh
is there bad if I relapse and I'll panic
right relapsed and those are the only
ones I remember because I just don't
want to go back you know yeah that's the
sunken place that is a simple place is
it not did you know him when he was you
know yeah that was the year afterward
and you know is when I came into his
life
and it was I mean you were a madman and
yeah yep there was a sketch what to have
where you you were a homeless black man
right and I was a head sketch right I
was your brother
oh we were brothers you don't grow wait
how'd you get brother confuse with
homeless tearing my chest oh the whole
things we were like some like sad family
oh look at this some kind of a parody of
some documentary show yeah it's like
they're like helping oh it's a home
replacement thing like we're gonna
surprise this
so we were somehow we were like
colorblind families but but why did you
think I was a homeless guy what I
thought that you were all was black man
yeah yeah and I was just like this
severed like Asian hair in your little
little little this is a much better
sketch and then you're like trying to
sell my head or your dream you're
pitching a much better sketch no talk
about back to the movie get out okay
name what may we please but the social
commentary in it like I feel like is it
a glimpse of what it might be in an
exaggerated way the african-american
experience is that it yeah absolutely
yes that's it that's what it feels like
yeah that's what it feels like when
you're in a but I'm sure it's the same
for I mean we're all mine almost all
minorities in here but oh I want to get
to your the Japanese man yeah okay so
the very very good guy first of all not
a lot of Japanese actors in Alabama
Alabama I had to go to you know you use
a friend Gigi Aoyama who is Ken Marina
father-in-law and amongst other things
he's great he's a karate master and he's
he's great in the movie yeah yeah but
look I mean the thing is there's many
reasons I did it okay okay one it's a
shout out to Rosemary's Baby where at
the end there's a Japanese guy there and
it helps like just paint this picture
that this society is [ __ ]
far-reaching this is an international
like that in Rosemary's Baby these
aren't just like some run-of-the-mill
devil worshippers this is the devil
worshipers right
and so that's scary to me is to the this
idea men to the idea that because the
broken English he's got to ask the
question more directly and it's like a
barrier yeah and in the hole and it
heightens the awkwardness of the
situation yes but then you know that's
lastly it's like yeah what doesn't make
you know old Japanese dude billionaire
comes he wants to buy it made perfect
sense to me now you say it now I know in
my head I was like there should have
been more Asians it would make more
sense for me for them to auction it
would make sense no I just I had more in
rigidly but I wanted to just whitewash
it a little bit but you know yeah
because I think at that point in the
movie you didn't think you didn't know
exactly what was going on right that
it's like they're doing surgical you
know yeah like oh that's I'm giving away
spoilers spoilers let's play a little
yeah yeah if you haven't seen it at this
point and you listened to your podcast
you're you're [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
ass watch his [ __ ] movie thanks but
subscribe know so but also subscribe but
JJJ no thank you collegiate you you've
always have problems in today ok due to
the Asian accent self weird when you
know when you your Asian accent is
enough too far it's not it's not what it
used to be
[Music]